a court in greece has found the leaders
of the country's far-right golden dawn
party guilty of running a criminal
organization
they face up to 15 years in prison a
supporter of the group was also
convicted of the murder of an
anti-fascist rapper in 2013. outside of
the courthouse police fired tear gas as
scuffles broke out at a rally
attended by thousands of anti-fascist
protesters
the guilty verdicts cap a marathon
five-year trial
with almost 70 defendants
i'm joined now by journalist anthony
karasova who is standing by in athens so
what more do we know
well the scuffles have actually pretty
much died down
they were pretty intense at some point
and quickly after this verdict
was sounded across the uh
the courthouse initially there were kind
of bursts
of celebration and clapping and applause
but then quickly we saw these scuffles
breaking out between far left
activists and the police
as a result the authority struck back
fired tear gas to disperse them uh
protesters also fled the scene and
tried to seek some kind of refuge in
inside streets
but at the same time however authorities
are telling us that these 2
000 plus policemen who were deployed for
fear of violence today
will remain on the ground uh in case
there is yet another flare-up
of uh violence that we saw earlier today
in the meantime we know that the verdict
uh it was released it took
five years to reach this verdict why so
long
well this is being called the biggest
trial of an
anti-fascist organization since the
nuremberg trials and it was supposed to
uh take for to run for just 18 months
but it
hit well into greece's financial crisis
that meant that there were a lot of
strikes lawyers who were
refusing to attend shutting down
the courtrooms there were also
facilities that were not available
i remember in one instance they couldn't
find a
video projector to project evidence that
was brought into
the case by the prosecution also
another circumstance where there wasn't
heating in the room that
forced the trial to be suspended but
ultimately
it also reflects uh greece's very very
slow
uh and problematic justice and how it
just takes forever
uh to get things adjudicated here uh
which of course however has become an
issue for the government which believes
and says in his firm and saying
um that it will want to remedy this
situation
what kind of implications does the
verdict have now for the ruling of the
government
well for the government it really it
spells nothing
uh substantively because this was a work
of justice
and uh in fact for the particular
government the conservative government
this was something that it wanted uh it
was
this particular government it was this
particular party
that launched this crackdown against uh
golden dawn uh so there is a huge sigh
of relief but that does not spell the
end
of um of far-right extremism
in greece uh with the end of this trial
there's still a lot of that lurking
around and that still has yet to be
addressed
effectively in this country anthony
anthony karasawa joining us from athens
thank you